alors le coup de coeur du si 17 cette
semaine va au festival play it again qui
vise à faire découvrir ou redécouvrir en
salle deux grands films de l'histoire du
cinéma
donc cette semaine trois films à
l'affiché la femme du dimanche qui est
un drame basé sur une histoire
scandaleuse avec une très belle
distribution mastroianni bisset
trintignant le deuxième film c'est
mauvais sens leos carax toulon connaît
un chef-d'oeuvre dire un film culte en
tout cas avec denis lavant et juliette
binoche et le troisième pour les enfants
pour la famille c'est un film qui
s'appelle la ferme des animaux où l'on
voit des animaux se rebeller dans une
ferme contre le fermier qui s'appelle
monsieur jones et n'oubliez pas aussi à
l'affiché du ciné sayles avec le second
coup de coeur le très beau fils de
nicolas bedos avec dorian thiviers et
nicolas bedos qui s'appelle monsieur et
madame adelman que nous avons encore à
la fiche
un très beau film qu'il faut soutenir et
voir en salles aux résultats parce que
c'est bien